we get one Tarzan yell first so I'd like
to hear you guys do it oh that was good
bill hader
Carol Burnett gathered some friends to
celebrate the 50th anniversary of her
groundbreaking variety show for a new
CBS special Moe rocof CBS Sunday morning
talked with a comedy legend about her
return to primetime oh good morning
morning Gail before she changed
television and made it a whole lot
better Carol Burnett was a theatre star
we met up with her at the Lambs Club in
New York not far from where she made her
Broadway debut and took her first step
toward stardom if comedy is all about
timing then Carol Burnett picked the
right moment to launch her TV show I'm
glad I'm the age I am and that I was the
age then but you couldn't do what we did
today why money 28-piece Orchestra all
those dancers say it could never be as
elaborate that's what we did you're
mounting a show that's what we do well
you know what I likened it to doing
summer stock
I must resist the temptations of the
flesh then again you would put on the
show
for her TV show Burnett had been a star
on Broadway that's where she learned to
play for a live audience and about
pacing the Carol Burnett Show was an
hour long and took little more than that
to take I never wanted to keep the
studio audience waiting I can't stand
that they give us our energy I have been
a guest on some set comes where 21
minutes and they take five hours
that's insane that's not necessary the
captain wouldn't let us serve if it
would be anything serious the cast
included Harvey Korman and Tim Conway
and just watch the picture Lyle Waggoner
and Vicki Lawrence who joined the
ensemble just out of high school she
didn't know what she's gonna say it's so
funny I would say she started out being
my kid sister and wound up being my
mother
the usual bathrobe Burnett began each
show not with the monologue but with a
Q&A with the audience which sometimes
led to discovering new talent
and this one woman I didn't loved her
and without missing a beat she turned to
the orchestra she said you made me love
you in the key of G it was just heaven
and the audience ate it up although
she's one of the funniest people ever to
be on TV there's one thing she can't do
I can't tell a joke to save my soul can
that would surprise a lot of people to
hear I don't say funny thing but I can
say things funny in a sketch that we're
doing that's a lot different than from
telling a joke when you would work
during the week on a bet that you knew
was gonna kill like the curtain rod and
went with the wind how did it feel sort
of in the moments before
you went before the audience with it oh
well I knew that was going to get a huge
laugh I said this is gonna be one of the
greatest sight gags in the history of
television and it is and that costumes
in the Smithsonian is gorgeous
everything I see from the show those old
sketches seems to hold up
is that what accounts for people's
attachment and affection for this show I
think yeah I think so it certainly
showed that we were having fun and the
reason I think that we have lasted here
we are 50 years and we're celebrating
each other's started 50 years ago that's
pretty wonderful it's as fresh today as
it was there how can you not love the
woman Carol Burnett was able to draw
some of the biggest names in
entertainment but one star she wished
she could have had on the show and she
didn't Frank Sinatra oh did she you know
she seems to have done everything whoa
is there anything does she have a bucket
list anything she was and one thing you
really surprised me is that she was
never asked to host Saturday Night Live
it startled me I asked her if she just
sketch comedy yes better than any and
king of sketch comedy I mean we there's
still time Foreman and Tim Conway
cracking themselves up on that show was
always funny I love that writing and you
know in they upped each other's game
exactly she said she was always home in
time for dinner with her family thank
you thanks you can watch the two-hour
Carol Burnett 50th anniversary special
Sunday night at 8:00 7:00 central right
here on CBS